so first of all thank you very much for
organizing this event and together with
this workshop and thank you very much
for the invitation and this talk is
about code representation learning from
unknown interventions actually this
title is not really precise i use the
interventions uh in that kind of very
very broad way because i would like to
draw the connection between this talk
and the theme of the workshop
essentially a better way to use this
title
so called this uh color representation
from chinese so why because essentially
if you know how interventions were
applied essentially you can find a color
model because um if you define
collapsible interventions this
definitely somehow somehow um circular
as a consequence if you can really
identify interventions and very often
times you can immediately see the
correlations now we can see how we can
do college discovery and color represent
translation learning from only chinese
okay so uh before talking about the
possible ways to
learn color representation from
observational data
based let me say something about this
talk this talk is essentially a summary
of a number of concrete works on how to
learn a color model and call
representation from data
in
this summary clearly not complete so i
apologize for that uh so some important
work might be overlooked and furthermore
compare compared to frederick's work uh
presentation this presentation would be
dry because it's a summary i would like
to consider all possible situations and
then we can see uh what kind with
assumption we have to make use of and
what information of the code model or
the code of representation can be
recovered
and if you have any questions please
just interrupt me okay so before we talk
about method or settings let's have a
look at the classical modularity
property of a code system essentially
when we say uh right here this is the
color system
essentially
here with the causal uh system we know
that
we have a modular way to think of the
relationships among those variables in
this example we know that we have three
processes to generate z x and y
respectively and those processes are not
are not related right they are not
relevant and this kind of uh modularity
property actually implies a lot of
statistical uh conditions that can be
discovered from that can be reflected in
the data
so here by uh by
by making use of the modularity problem
we know that the changes in the column
model or following the column model
would be first of all minimal
because you cannot reduce the change in
different modules right to a small
number of modules and second of all
those changes are independent
right because those chains are not
related to each other and then if you
observe multiple realizations of some
underlying quantity uh distribution then
those changes would be exactly
independent
so now let's see how we can make use of
the independent the problem the property
of independent and minimal chinese of a
code system or uh to recover the
property of the code system by analyzing
data here by chinese i mean two kind of
changes we may have changed in the
values of the merit variables
and sometimes we can have change in the
hidden variables or the hidden
parameters in the system but in any case
we have the property of minimal and
independent changes
and here by a minimum change i mean the
following event a new chain
representation explains the conditional
independent relations uh in the
variables and the distribution change
for all the distribution across
different domains
with a minimum number of tiny
conditional distributions
clearly the two online chord processes
specify the minimum channel property
right and now the property the problem
is how we can recover the underlying
chord representation this is a clear
inverse problem right in order to
recover truth we have to establish the
identifiability result so this talk will
be uh many focus on the identifiability
result you can see in different
scenarios how we can show that the
underlying model of underlying
representation is actually
identifiable from the data
let's here consider
all possible combinations essentially we
consider three dimensions the first
dimension is the way that the data is id
the second dimension is whether we can
benefit from parametric constraints on
the color influence
or to call the model and the third one
is whether there are latent confounders
in the underlying color model so we have
three dimensions now let's consider
different combinations
let's start with a classical color
discovery result so we are considering
id data without parametric constraints
on the column influence and
we can first of all let's suppose that
there are no latent commander in the
system then we know that we can with the
condition
uh with the commission maintained by the
method or confirmed as method we can
recover the amount of human class with
pc or some other method and even if we
allow compounders in an online code
process we can still recover some
equipment costs right although in many
cases such results may not be informed
enough because generally speaking their
results are not unique however you can
see in this uh very basic situation we
can still say something about online
underlying code relations a typical
assumption underlying those methods
including pc and fci uh is edge
minimality is physicalness and the
physician is essentially implies edge
minimality
and we can consider each edge is as one
way to change the conditional
distribution of the target variable
given other causes in other words edgy
minimality can also be considered as one
particular instantiation of the minimal
charging principle so we would like to
have a minimum minimum number of ways to
change the condition distribution to
produce the data
the data dependence
now let's go further
so
let's see how we can benefit from
primary constraints right here you can
see three typical
constraints on the functional column
model so that we can identify color
direction without making use of temporal
information so here you can see a linear
nangoji model and who's non-linear code
model and editing on the model basically
here we benefit from a property of
independent changes only in the right
column direction
under the assumption uh
on the
caudal influence then only the right
direction can give rise to independent
changes between the noise term and the
hypothetical call and in the wrong
direction we're going to show that
the chinese cannot be cannot be
independent
so here we have identifiability we
benefit from independent change property
and okay
we can successfully identify the color
direction and if you have many variables
you can identify the whole deck i make
use of this result together with the
previous one
now let's go further what if we have a
parametric constraints on the code
influence and we also have latent
compounders so in this case you can see
we can get some stronger results for
instance with over complete independent
component analysis based method we can
recover the uh latent compounds and on
some further conditions we can also
recover the color differences over the
method variables
and unfortunately those those methods
assume that the latent components are
mutually independent in many cases
latent components may be related right
let's just consider
mental conditions right with
questionnaires we try to yield
fundamental conditions and the mental
conditions may be related so we have to
go further to recover everything in the
relations among the latent variables
uh silver
which
ricardo peter clark and
richard basically have been using the
vanishing tetrad conditions to recover
the latent variables and their relations
this structural constraint is generally
pretty
strong because we have to assume that
for each latent variable there are at
least three pure measured variables at
the indicators
and
furthermore with this method
essentially we can only recover the
equivalent class of the column model
over the latent variables so it's not
fully identifiable
now let's see how we can further benefit
from the non-gaussian assumption on the
on the noise term
so suppose in this column model right
here you can see li variables are latent
variables they are called related we
observe x i variables now we try to
analyze the measure the variables x i's
to recover the latent variables li what
can we do
so right here
first of all we assume the noise terms
are non-governing of course the
relationships in this case are still
assumed to be gaussian we try to benefit
from this constraint
and then we can show that this whole
color model including latent verb and
their relations can be immediately
identified by making use of the
so-called generalized independent noise
condition and hereby or gene condition
by gene condition i mean the following
thing suppose we have two subsets of
demanded variables y and z we say the
ordered pair y z satisfy the gene
condition if and only if there exists a
non-zero can be linear combination of
the y variables that is independent from
z
now you can see we can immediately test
for this condition given the two sets of
variables y and z
and furthermore this condition has some
very nice graphical interpretation
essentially if the yz satisfy gene
condition we know that there exists an
exogenous set of the parent's latent
parents of the y variables that can give
separate y from z by making use of this
graphical interpretation then we can
recover the whole structure in two steps
some situations we can have three steps
so step one is to find the caller
clusters here by cluster i mean a group
of random verb made the variables that
share the same latent parents so here we
can find the clusters and then we can
also find the code orders of the latent
variables and furthermore if immediately
you can estimate those linear
coefficients so the whole column model
is identifiable by making use of this
easily testable condition called the
gene condition okay now let's go further
here you can see some quick external
results so we analyze the t-shirt
burnout data with this method uh in this
dataset there are 28 method variables
and we recovered all those latent
variables as you can see from here
and we found that we cover the model
together with the color order of the
latent variables are consistent with the
hypothetic the hypothesized model by
experts so it's very nice because you
can really recover the latent variables
and their relations in this case
you can go further
now you can see we can even recover this
latent hierarchical structure from the
measured variables only x i's why this
is because uh essentially the linear
quadrant influences are transitive uh in
this case consider this example first of
all we can analyze the measured
variables and then we can find those
hidden variables and then we can
consider the merit variable as a
surrogate for the
latent variable and then we can go to a
higher level eventually all color
variables the latent color variables
here together with their relations will
be identifiable in this case
so the procedure is rather simple of
course here we have to in this work we
just constrain the relation linear and
furthermore you can see minimality has
been assumed essentially here by
minimality i mean admin managing
in me edging minimality is a one kind of
um
independent chain uh condition
so
now let me just show some
purely theoretical results we can even
find the necessary and sufficient
condition on the structure so that it's
identifiable from metadata
here on the right you can see all
identifiable code structures uh if you
have three major variables x123
right here and again we make use of
minimality and the although the theory
is very nice uh giving a graph you can
quickly check whether this uh structure
is identifiable involving related verb
latent variables uh from metadata
however
so far there does not exist any
efficient procedure to ultimate
structure in the general case so this is
the purely theoretical result however
you can see we can really benefit from
aging minimality in order to recover
latent variables and their relations
now let's go to a different setting
suppose we don't have id data now so it
says we have non-id data and by 90 data
i mean two different kinds of data one
is uh
time series the traditional time series
data essentially we have data generated
by a fixed time delay called model
right here we would like to estimate the
time delay called model from metadata
in the first let's consider situation
without latent components and if there
are no instantaneous relations then you
can use granular causality to recover
the time dilated correlation essentially
chronic causality organic code analysis
can be considered as a way to combine
conditional independent-based methods
together with the temporal constraints
that
future cannot cause the
past
furthermore
you can even allow the instantaneous
correlations by if you don't have the
parametrical conditions then still you
can make use of a condition in my best
method actually granular make the use of
this method to see the instantaneous
relations among the measured variables
and furthermore if you assume linear
relations or linear linear numbers
then everything is identifiable
including time delayed and instantaneous
relations
so we can benefit from parametric
constraints in this case as well
now let's go further
so this is pretty amazing i just would
like to summarize one word we're going
to slide so
right here you can see the setting we
just measured variables x i's we always
i always use x i the measured variables
and we assume the measured variables
were generated by a invertible nonlinear
transformation g applied to some hidden
variables z we would like to recover z
and their relations
right so in this work let's assume the
latent processes follow a temporal
column model with for instance
completely non-primary model
so now in this case even if the temporal
column model is completely
non-parametric in a general situation zi
variables latent processes are
identifiable from the time series data x
i
why this is because we can benefit from
the time delayed called relations
and furthermore if you have
non-stationarity in the noise or
non-stationarity in the college
influence you can further improve the
result
and of course if you have primarical
constraints generally speaking we can
further improve improve the results uh
so the estimation procedure may be
statistically more efficient
why do we have this this result so here
let me try to give the intuition
right here you can see
this is essentially the latent
processes
each latent variable was produced by the
previous ones right and given the
previous one the latent variable lesson
process that would be conditionally
independent because in this work there
are no instantaneous relationship
between the latent processes and then if
you
have a nonlinear transformation on the
latent variables then generally speaking
you are going to introduce the
dependence of instantaneous dependence
between the latent variables
as a consequence
we know that oh only the true one can
satisfy the condition intended
relationship between the latent
processes given their past values
okay so that's why the whole process of
all the latent processes are actually
identifiable uh i will skip the
experimental results if you are
interested please have a look at the
papers so you can see the results on
simulated data and unreal data basically
you can take video data and input there
you can analyze you can recover some
interesting data processes
okay now uh let's go further
in this case we have previously we have
time deleted correlations now suppose we
have instantaneous correlations and we
have independent but not identically
distributed data what does that mean so
you may have multi-domain data but
within domain the data basically uh
would be id however the distribution can
be different across different domains or
you can have time series data but the
the sample would be independent over
time however the distribution may change
over time right so this is known as
independent but not identically
distributed data in this case we would
like to ultimately insert instantaneous
correlations from such data
first of all it's clear that we can
directly benefit from the distribution
changes and by enforcing the minimal and
the independent changes of the column
model in many cases we can recover the
underlying two column model uniquely
and even if we don't have any
parametrical constraints and here you
can see i use this color for uh latent
component we allow a specific type of
latent component known as the solute
compounders so if the solu if the
component can be written as a function
of uh surrogate like domain index or
time index then we can allow such
compounders we can still get the right
result uh even if we have such
compounders
and furthermore if you have paramedical
assumptions that linearity assumptions
then you can develop slightly more
efficient approaches
to recovering the underlying column
model from data
okay
so specifically in this work you can see
what tasks we are going to uh
deal with first of all from such data
non-stationary or heterogeneous data we
can immediately determine
which code modules change over time
across domains as you can see from here
and furthermore we can find the right
color skeleton and then by making use of
independent changing principle uh
basically by that i mean
the distribution of the cause and this
conditional distribution of the impact
in the chord would change independently
then we can find the color direction
note that this property of independent
chinese includes invariant mechanisms
and even causes as special cases because
a constant is independent from
everything
so we can find the direction
and uh if needed you can also find the
low dimensional real life a little
dimensional representation of the chain
called the mechanism by making use of
some kernel tweak essentially you can
find a non-parametric way to reduce the
dimensionality of the chinese okay so uh
if you would like to see some results
please have a look at the paper
this is uh
that setting now let's go further so in
the previous setting we didn't allow
genuine data compounders we only allowed
a specific type of compounders that can
be written as functions of the circuit
variable now
suppose we have latent compounders a
very simple way to
find the latent compounders by making
use of nonlinear ica so this is the
second learning ic or nominal
independent component analysis so they
observe the variables x i's follow this
model so there are a nonlinear transform
invertible linear transformation of the
latent variable zi
those latent variables zi's are mutually
independent
we know that the solutions to nanny ica
are highly non-unique
basically there would exist an infinite
number of solutions to a nonlinear ca in
the traditional setting
however if you allow the distributions
of the independent variable zi to change
across domains then generally the i's
the latent variables can be recovered
from the measured variables
why basically here i try to give
intuition
with this graphical equation
here you can see
those variables zi variables are
conditionally independent giving the uh
surrogate variables you can either think
of theta i theta 1 02 as some underlying
factor to change the distribution of the
independent variables right so given
those things c one z two are independent
within within domain with each other for
each distribution the values of zeta one
theta two are fixed
now g the fixed function so g transforms
the z i variable to the x-i variables
and we would like to recover the i
variables from x-i variables right
now you can see z-i's are conditional
independent in each domain because here
we don't have the link between them
however if you apply a non-linear
transformation to the eye then
unfortunately you are going to introduce
uh the additional spiritual dependence
efficiency i variables so again this is
something like a minimality condition
with the wrong solution you are going to
you you are going to introduce
additional dependence between the uh the
latent variables that means by enforcing
the conditional independent relations
between the latent variables
within across different domains then we
can recover them up to the component
while the transformations
and clearly zi variable the component
for xi variables right okay so here you
can see in this setting we can recover
the independent underlying compounders
let's go further now suppose the merit
variables follow
the same model but the components of the
data variables component of z and latent
variables are causally related
and some correlations are assumed to
change over time first of all if the
caller relations over the latent
variables are fixed then we cannot
recover the latent variables and their
correlation why because in this case we
can always write down
the generating process for x
this way x i the measured variables can
always be considered as a nonlinear
transformation of independent variables
in this case as long as the column model
over the decent variable is fixed what
if some of the correlations change over
time across different domains
here you can see basically illustration
this is suppose this is the two process
we have z one z two d three d four you
can see a chord model for electrical
purposes and here by theta i mean
this chord relationship from z1 to z2 is
fixed the chord influence from z2 v3 to
z4 is also fixed however the chord
difference from z2 to z3 may change and
here by chanting i mean there are two
ways to change the chord difference you
can have the chaining in the chord
influence from z two to three or you can
have the
chain in the chord level uh noise
variable in v3
first of all
we can reduce this mixing procedure to a
canonical one here you can see
basically we can just replace the latent
variable that does not involve uh
that is not involved in any change in
chord relationship
with the independent variable
as you can see from here we use z1 and
e1 and e4 which are mutually independent
to replace z1 z4 this is always the case
however for this part we cannot reduce
them to independent variables
meaning that if you apply nonlinear ica
you cannot recover z2 and v3 at all
now we can show two two results first of
all we can show that the invariant part
those zebra e variables can be recovered
up to its subspace that means they
recover the e variable will not receive
any contribution from the z i z
variables
which are involved in a changing chord
relationship and furthermore all those
relationships involved in the changing
chord relations zi variables can also be
identified up to its subspace
so you should recover the z variable
involved in a changing chord
relationship would be a function of z2
and z3 and the furthermore if you make
some fun assumptions for instance if you
assume that the color mode is linear
gaussian then we can show that z2 can
also be recovered from x-i variables
and unfortunately we cannot recover z3
because any mixture of z2 and d3 would
also uh basically do the same work
without the further sparsity constraints
we cannot recover these three variables
however we can recover the causes of the
uh variable on which the code of
influence change
okay so basically this is purely
theoretical and
to summarize
this talk is about the code
representation learning essentially we
like to see two things first of all what
props is a code system can we make use
of uh to recover the underlying code of
representation second of all how can we
establish identifiability result to make
sure that what can work what it can
recover from data is uh consistent with
the ground tools
so we just saw what information we made
use of and uh the identifiability result
and here i covered two levels of changes
you can have changes in value many
variables or you can have change in
hidden variables or hidden parameters
and the
very rough or terrible message that
follows the latent variables latent
causal variables and their relations
involved in changing code relations are
generally identifiable
if there are if the correlations
overlapping variables do not change then
generally speaking we cannot recover
those variables we have just considered
them as a background however if they are
involved in the chaining code relations
then we can just locate and recover
those variables together with the color
influences okay thank you very much uh
that's all for this talk
uh by the way i want uh to
uh
thank my collaborators including clark
peter bernard applebee and
willian and sean
thank you very much
thank you very much phone
so we will keep questions for afterwards
in a panel discussion because i think
there will be a lot of questions of how
this causal representation learning
framework that was just discussed now
and how that relates to the coarsening
that frederick described before in
particular when you're in the setting
that kuhn had
at the end right mainly where you don't
have any edges pointing from observance
to later ones
so i think we'll keep that discussion
for later on in the panel discussion i
hope you'll be able to join
great thank you very much okay and so
then we'll have a break now um we'll get
some nice coffee outside and some
discussions and then we'll be back here
at
11.
i